hi everybody welcome to another session
of saying this chess club place two
people we have Dennis LaRue assistant
manager of the chess club he is
basically stooping down to the viewers
levels and we're gonna he's gonna take
some challengers I am of course Tony
Chen we will begin as soon as somebody
challenges on chess comm make sure it's
a rated game bliss time control do you
do you play bullet too or do you
let's say no and you could say that 3o
is as fast as you're gonna get out of me
well maybe I'll acceptable it okay I'll
enjoy - so basically your choices are
five oh three - three oh let's start
with those three and then if if he if
you once up a little bit during the show
we might take some bullet we might take
some other time control so go ahead and
challenge us chess calm as you see well
first of all let's give a shout out to
our man in the back Danny Machuca he is
the one that making things happen
also another man that back i Isaac I'm
gonna be holding my hand here a lot like
this because he's supposed to be putting
a fireball in my hand so we're gonna see
if this actually comes true or not so if
you wanted a wife on my hand on the
table in the entire Stroeve that's why
okay
put Isaac to work yeah well since we
don't have any challengers yet why don't
we go ahead and just play a random game
right okay play some listen Danny McHugh
go can you do us a favor and put the
chess comm link on there perfect thank
you very much
all right well while everything is on
the way to open challenges okay just
play just hit just hit hip oh here's one
okay you fired a shot makan I know you
you play this all the time all right
I love it so right now our rating our
this is what time control is black 500k
so right now it's before I move geez
so right now our blitz rating is 1701
and let's try to make a goal of eighteen
eighteen you want me to gain a hundred
point out an hour and a half yeah you
can do that is ridiculous Jessie cried
gained like 500 points so grand match
you can you can gain at least 550 for
that I think let's try for it let's try
for it don't let the club down I'm like
a club like you're goal-oriented we
always we always try to aim aim for so I
forgot about this we always tried to aim
for higher right well so we are playing
again shock makan and he is a regular
Challenger for us so which is pretty
cool then uh as you see if you're
joining us on YouTube there's a there's
a link on the chat you can click that
link for chess comm for our info and
then challenged us to a game rated games
only this time control right now the
whole plate so the shortest time control
play is three oh yeah that's right
alright Ludwig how's it going thank you
for joining us abdel thank you for
joining us
where you guys from you guys from st.
Louis us somewhere outside the US let us
know I'm always curious of how many
people we get outside the country so we
want to be international all right we
have 21 people viewing right now which
is great for those 21 people let me tell
you what's going on here at the st.
Louis s Club in the next couple of weeks
so we have this coming Saturday November
2nd we have the $5 Thanksgivings open
satellite tournament which if you win if
you get three out of three and you win
Armageddon games you get free entry into
Thanksgiving open that is November 29th
through these
first so thanks again me open is
typically our biggest tournament of the
year we usually draw somewhere between
like a hundred to 150 players there is a
cap of this tournament of 150 this
because that's how many people we can
actually fit in this club so if you want
to register make sure you register early
so you can get a spot because we will be
I think I I'm thinking we will be
selling out on that day what the
satellite tournament oh the thing-thing
see any open because we're capping in
150 uh-huh and we have as of right now I
think we have we have about 20 people
already pre-registered so I think it's
gonna be a big one yeah we will cap it
yeah yeah sounds right so so that lose
yeah so thanks give me open since it's
such a big tournament it does have a big
cash prize fund ten thousand dollars
total
unconditionally guaranteed so that's
where we give me ten thousand dollars
giving out no matter what because of
that the pre registration fee is
normally a hundred and ten dollars but
if you register by this Saturday it's
only eighty dollars right and if you
register by the November twenty seconds
only a hundred so make sure you
registered this Saturday if you want to
plan on playing so you can save yourself
basically thirty bucks
and you know everybody can use some
spare cash it is free sure Danny Machuca
unlisted that's true that's true oh
sorry I was like frat boy hanging on the
table put put a put a ball there put
fireball there real quick
dang it so he said no that's a I'm
looking I'm not gonna lie I'm not sure
Dakota he pretty straight up white he's
pretty to lie to me because he's so he's
gonna do it he's not doing it oh no I
just so basically it's like why do I
miss my heart it goes like you know what
else what else
c'est la vie you know all right so uh so
that is all the club tournaments going
on in November down oh and as always
there is November we have a nice
tournament every more
November nights it's every Tuesday
starting at 7:00 p.m. and it's a four
round tournament so it's like oh it's
not four to four to five round
tournament depending on the month but
it's every Saturday every Tuesday and
that is every Tuesday is a round for a
tournament for the month of course
November 16th
we have Saturday night blitz that's
usually a pretty popular tournament for
every for all the locals a lot of
players so make sure just make sure if
you're if you're in the area come come
by I don't know how it is
internationally but here in the US
there's usually like a three to five day
break around Thanksgiving so that's what
we're trying to try to get into Ludwig
you're from friends perfect thank you
for joining us from friends I love it
Jojo hello from Slovenia I love it thank
you very much for joining us Abdel
Morocco all right we have just
everywhere around the world
thank you very much Daniel Rowe burger
nice to see you again a regular so thank
you very much for participating in this
make sure if you want to play
Dennis LaRue make sure to challenges on
chess calm the link on the chat well I'm
blaming the fact that I'm down a piece
on you telling me you can do that mine
I'm high I I'm actually I'm not a not
only am I not a fence it fended glad
you're saying that cuz it's my job it's
my job to job to keep me distract so our
viewers can get a usually it's a GM
plane so I view us and get a chance but
now wellness why yeah okay fair all
right yeah I mean then Dennis is a
self-proclaimed so chess master so don't
lie to me Dennis
mind you you're you know I heard him
saying it a couple of times so let's not
you know let's let's just keep it keep
it seems that yeah Danny Machuca has
company and never mind they're gonna
turn my mic off and as always Danny
Machuca
I welcome you to get a mic and talk to
our viewers so Danny is only talking to
you guys through the chat he's someone
actually putting all the links up so if
you wanna go through the chat and say
say hi Danny but
just pretend that that didn't happen
that didn't happen that was a practice
game practice you know a good game dude
shotgun shotgun yeah good hand to you
good job good job Danny it's only to get
sad back there let's play this guy nice
remember our goal is to get to 80 we
need to make a step forward Tony okay
we're taking a step forward all right
all right all right so continue on so we
talked about all the open tournaments
and now we're going to talk about some
special close tournament so a lot of
high-level GM's the one that's coming up
first here is the winner chess classic
and that is starting November 9th we do
have we do have a list of all the
players that are going to be
participating so if you want to check
out the player field go to us chess
champs calm and select a winner chess
classic and see who's playing if you
want if you're trying to follow somebody
in there follow us on our follow us on
our stream because we're gonna be
streaming that basically for every round
the tournament I think yep
hour-and-a-half broadcast every day yeah
what about dude did you already chat up
the GCT stuff now yeah that's after
after this but so AB right after winning
a classic here we have the st. Louis
norm invitational fear me that is
beginning November 21st through the 28th
that is also a lot of high a lot of
great players GM's we have a couple it's
a norm tournament so we do have IMS FM's
trying to get their norm points so if
you want to see how the up-and-coming
great players join us for that we'll be
streaming for that I think I'm not sure
bring a streaming for that but hopefully
we will if not you can always look at
the results on us chess champs calm okay
all right see if there's any chats here
shock my contest thank you for playing
oh yeah a good game I'm really bad all
right
but you I see why your 900 rated domain
your phone oh whoa let's not let's not
trash lost the game yeah okay okay fair
enough
dan Jenny Machuca in the back if you uh
if you want to pick up the slack for
Isaac go ahead and put a fireball in my
hand right now I like this is your dream
Tony or or if you prefer shooter energy
beam out of my pants right now all right
I guess not so it's gonna I'm gonna try
that all should the entire show so
hopefully they'll get it going okay
Danny's laughing in the back cuz he's
funny
yeah I want you to do it man I want you
to do it everyone's having a good ha ha
alright alright so we talked about all
the things that are gonna be happening
here let's talk about all the big
tournaments that are going to be
happening in the Grand chest tour so all
those of you who do not know the grand
chest or is it is a series of
tournaments for the top players in the
world
Oh Daniel Rowe Berger from Sweden thank
you very much for joining us
what I'm making a mad I did some I hung
my bishop on c4 I'm yeah I can't do this
or it but I can't is this still the
night 905 man is man well it's all your
fault dude I played on you I will I do
not I refuse to hold myself accountable
I have refused it so I take pride in you
saying that I'm pride of I'm proud of
that
that's my job so you know alright
there's I have to I have two jobs on the
show one is to be the colorful
commentator the other is to be the
distraction for the players so ya know I
you know let the public know yeah Tony
is a good friend at work but right now I
hate you Tony you're making me lose
Chesky I think I think I think the word
friend friend is little stretching on
too far acquaintances acquaintances oh
wow Oh hurts
all right anyway we're continuing on the
Grantchester so it's starting pretty
soon November 6 is super bet wrapping
and blitz that is a nice leg of the
grand chest or and then after so you can
actually view streaming for that you can
look at all the player field streaming
on grand chest or calm okay we have a
couple of different sister sites that we
we track and we take care of aside from
our own we have u.s. chess champs like I
said before also a grand chest or so
check those two out after a super bet we
have Tata Steel one of the bigger
tournaments that pretty much I think
everybody I know in the chest way
actually follows that so make sure you
followed that as well
November 22nd Tata Steel and then the
last leg of the grand Chester is London
the finals GCT finals and that starts on
December 2nd and that will also so all
those events will be streamed and info
on Grantchester or comm so check that
out alright so let's see what our
viewers are talking about how great I am
was watching the stream and didn't
realize you except in my challenge man
come on
well now we're playing dude you know
your Chong is doing good he's doing
great
we're all proud for this guy I'm happy
for you still losing yeah but on this is
a check as our good friend GM a coke
Cobian says check a ruski yeah yeah he
just say check or users check guys -
he'd like to do that yeah check okay
give him no check over there you go
there you go never check is a shank it
might be me Oh looks like who's this
guy's name
fear fear salon oh yeah I'm useless okay
there's less you are up in material but
it looks like Dan is the AMIA whatever I
name is okay then make up a name for me
Dennis Dennis is proclaiming that he's
gonna checkmate you soon
oh you're taking back your words man I
just said I got a chance Alex hello from
poop okay thank you very much for for
that I don't know if you're trying to be
funny there or you're not funny actually
that that's pretty cool arias was I when
I set out put a fireball in my hand I
think they're playing not putting like
some kind of I think I'm winning my hand
see I have made soon in some way
somebody tell me Danny figure this out
danny is there mate yeah there's
something any Queen there's something in
here but yeah obviously yeah well you
got a start here and he comes here and
something happens yeah but nine nights
there okay cool sounds good thing dies
yeah good game good game
nice try nice try thank you for giving
us the boys yeah oh god okay no we're
gonna okay mister lunk 63 this guy also
yes
lunk you're up let's see how you do it
funk you up um okay neon he wanted to
see me on may I play you know you can't
play challenged us to a game there is a
link to chess calm at the top of this
chat click it challenge to the game
please time control rated games only
okay Oh Britney Monroe is saying let him
have let him have it Dennis let him have
it
yeah I'm gonna let them have it Britney
is uh yeah Britney is a staff member
here at the st. Louis chess club she's
actually upstairs give you a reference
for any new viewers we're in that the
studio is in the basement of the Chess
Club the main floor is right above us
and Britney is up there joining us on a
chat so love to have all our employees
here just one big happy chess family we
will be if you win will be unhappy if I
lose correct correct
is that the moral of the story yeah
tell me what to do is that wrong all
right as any new chest fans if you
follow the chest world at all you know
that the Fifi de the Vita grain Swiss
tournament just and the recently winner
Wang Hao from China went on tight breaks
against Fabiano and he is now qualified
for the Canada's tournament so there's
our shape so there's four people already
qualified for Canada's Fabiana karana
Rajab of King Lear in Wang Hong those
are the four there are two more
tournaments you can qualify and still
left and that is Hamburg Germany and Tel
Aviv Israel so whoever wins basically
wins the top players in those two
tournaments will qualify as well plus
there is a player who has the highest
average rating they're gonna be
qualified also a wild card chosen by the
organizer so we don't know who that is
yet but some of the top leaders in those
categories are Alexander Gris shook mom
mother of onigiri was she lick my Sheila
Grove and Alex Cinco so I love basically
top top 20 top 10 in the world so make
sure you follow those tournaments that's
going to be really good all right
and I said to point out this is the
first year where two Chinese players
have made it to the candidates I am of
Chinese descent so you know power power
let's see to do can I challenge you if I
have a test time on chest comm what I
don't know what that means what
I don't know what that is either
Daniel RORO burger I don't we typically
don't play chess that console we don't
we don't I don't know I don't know what
that weird so let me spell it out for us
yeah explain it explain it
pretend I'm a five-year-old kid explain
to me if you need to write like a big
paragraph to do it alright I was here
okay let's see what's going on the chess
world so if you guys so there is a world
Fisher random tournament a championship
going on right now if you are following
it
I actually so if you were a big so we're
actually the club is great friends with
yasser Sarah Wan he's a big influence
here he is and a couple of people were
actually streaming about that and check
it out it's pretty cool
I always love listening to yeah yes I
talk about chess it's fun gives a lot of
stories gives a lot of background
references so any new people who are not
following you can always follow along
with just from where they are now all
right
somebody said why didn't king capture
bishop of on f7 i what why didn't oh
because the queen hangs on d8 sir that's
why and you know ask can you make a
tournament are you asking me are we can
we make a tournament for on the stream
like just we're not doing yeah we that's
Texas for that's a it is one too much
work into is just not not sure we can
poke poke all that off with just ran
random viewers on a on an Internet I'm
not saying anything bad about the
viewers just keep it falling this is
totally trash talking you guys yes right
highly of you that's right then we just
at the begin the show then we say you
were they all know is just my arrogance
is a defense mechanism
myself Wow how yours I have it we get
each other I haven't been how are you
are you winning I'm not winning I don't
want to talk about it okay to say just
TJ you do you whenever open everything
had to talk about it usually means he's
missing so I guy I someone claim my
blunder two pawns in the in the
beginning but I got him back I got those
pawns back am I gonna lose stuff if I
don't play right here probably I I do
want to give you or some updates on our
streaming times usually so two today
like today Tuesdays we stream at 12 like
we're going to do now Wednesday Thursday
Friday so easily stream at 3 however
tomorrow tomorrow Wednesday only
tomorrow we're stirring a stream at 12
again okay so make sure to follow us at
12 I will be tweeting that on Twitter so
make sure you give you follow saw follow
us on any social media you'll know about
it so make sure to check us out tomorrow
at 12 12 local time I can't account for
any international times I'm not that
good alright you're great
ah you're amazing my heart that was
broken by I Isaac has now put together
yeah yeah yeah Isaac's a mean guy
sometimes he means well he means well I
like him a lot I don't I don't my god as
nice as me I know I don't like the fact
that he says he's gonna put fireballs in
my hand but he doesn't well I've got
nothing for you there
I wonder if Danny is it oh if I is it
okay if I like leave the screen for like
10 10 seconds because I want to throw up
because I want to throw something at
Isaac throws and then come back I'll be
like pretend that was a fireball that's
need you to put it in my hand I think
throwing things is bad sportsmanship
unless you're playing a game where
you're supposed to throw something
Touche that's definitely true I'm just
sharing my thoughts no it's it's true I
agree with the making all the for all
the kid kids are out there viewing us
good sportsmanship is key so let's not
let's not try to be like me okay I'm
trying to be I'm trying to be funny so
that's all this well I put you on the
spot yeah whatever would have kids all
the kids on there what do we do at the
beginning of chessgame shake hands say
good luck I said hand away I slap it
okay no crush you and also what do we do
at the end shake hands and say good game
hmm
[Music]
you're supposed to and that's why I tell
the kids but I don't know how to do that
at places that I've seen many kids who
were just like seriously throw throw the
King on the ground then walk away
yeah oh my come on come on no it is life
is all about winning and losing both you
can't win all the time that's true yeah
and how would you have a concept of
winning without one of loss there it is
our resident philosopher right there it
is actually jesse has an our current
residency and actually has a lady you
can acclaim but he is only gonna be here
for in there are two days so after that
you are like hour after that yeah after
that's all you man I get it oh yeah look
at that free fall look at me go oh my
gosh she's taking stuff everybody's
taking stuff what's happening oh that's
not good I know first we say check to
the misérable gang check to you love it
love it
ooh what's happening um and we'll give
them the exchange we don't care about
that
that's a big exchange no no everything's
fine okay don't don't
that's you amazing as you heard
everything is fine so we're probably
gonna win this play a question mark well
I don't know what's gonna happen I looks
like I'm up on time here so let's say
I'm good neoman McKenzie you have a
Seattle Seahawks logo are you in from
Seattle
are you a Seahawks fan who I didn't see
all this up now asked what is Dennis
drinking a sprite he's drinking a sprite
not not a sprite hand full of alcohol
just right whoa whoa I I clarified oh
god he's gonna make me or something all
right we I got off topic we're oh oh
yeah oh yeah we're all Fisher random
championship that's that's going on
right now you can check it out it's
actually I've actually never replaced
Fisher random games but I'm not that
good at regular chess I'm not gonna try
a eight point it's good good good tryout
lunk good Cylons a good game I try the
game we're not gonna talk about analysis
or no no what that's challenge something
sixteen sixteen eleven right there I
with this guy okay Yamato you're up so
I've got a plus I've got a plus score
against you guys right now love it what
are you gonna do about it
can the handle handle the pastries you
know Oh Sonia Macca's you are from Siena
good job you you are cielos she's seeing
us man okay cool I was I mean how do you
how do you feel about the team this year
is you know I actually haven't followed
the Seahawks closely since they won the
Super Bowl a while back you know but Oh
Luke
Luke's a crazy game X good game exclam
good game and Brittany if I'm upstairs
says yeah yeah go nice thank you for the
chin Brittany we love it
whoa whoa I'm getting everything all
mixed up
are you like are you are you playing are
you playing the danishes why no yeah
yeah it's that I wanted to but this guy
wanted me to refute the Sicilian instead
so I am refuting the Sicilian with I
don't know if you're like Mike where
he's like I'm gonna Ron playing black on
the play c5 no matter what hey are you
Mike is famous for this this opening
strategy ya know cuz it works I'm not
gonna lie like even even if I tell
people look he's gonna play see if I
every time I only seem like maybe one
person played before like one person so
it's a lie or together to get tricky
with him but well I heard that on the
other site that we play on that someone
with the handle drunk lifeguard just
keep screaming him
I think it's Isaac in the back he's
really strong Mike just can't handle
that could be true I think that could be
true and his drunk lifeguarded account I
keep getting off the topic okay sorry
Fischer will rant Fischer random Chess
Championships so there was a tie in the
semifinals but it was broken looks like
it was broken today
[Music]
in a second so it looks like Carlson won
this I've got a second win with black
over Fabiano and now it has Lee has a
lead in the match so I mean if you're
gonna bet on anybody why wouldn't you
bet on the worldsheet champion right so
all right cool I'm actually gonna check
out I'm actually gonna play a couple
games of fish at random just to have you
never play I've never played I've never
played
I usually don't play I don't even play
buck-buck house to be honest with you
yeah I never seen you play bug house
this is true Danny is in the back
commenting we can fix that because he
wants to play bug house oh I thought he
was talking about my game oh is he
talking about your game we talk about it
anyway I can't oh oh he's on my when you
play back house okay who are the four
who are the four Isaac loves bug house
well before Isaac place bug house he
needs to put a firebomb money doesn't
like bug house put a fire ball my hand
right now let's see Abdel says you have
a route Dennis I do have a row okay
is that is that the they tell they're
commenting I don't know what they're
singing exactly what and then how about
this game were yes and maybe I probably
he's referring to the fact that both of
my roofs are more or less active than
this guy's this guy's it's not um you're
down on a lot of time you know
am I really oh yeah okay so better speed
up here let's speed it up they call me
super fast Dennis that's what they call
me they've never really called me that
okay um we're at sixteen ninety oh okay
so you went down below something hundred
without a first game room okay I'm so
sorry
I'm not honest failed fair I'm not
trying to make fun a mess I'm just
saying facts I'm gonna let our viewers
know what's going on oh I heard Tony
hurt
some facts hurt the truth hurts there is
some GM that used to say that at some
point Street arts for tires right truth
hurts everybody yeah first everybody or
step to something is free our first step
to fail
is trying sorry okay I mean oh yes true
the deep do you are you are you one of
those people that I think you should
never try yeah you'll never feel that
way hmm you'll never feel that it's true
it's true you guys just don't get it all
right
we have 41 people watching right now
great I want to increase our viewers so
all the viewers right right now if you
want to pull up like a phone or another
computer or something and join chat
again give us some more viewers give us
a you guys need from us do we need to be
more entertaining do I need to be more
obnoxious possibly possibly you you need
to have like a like a cat like a
catchphrase
you know how Emeril Lagasse had has the
fam you need something something won't
like that some short something is short
so nice sweet and it has to be like an
onomatopoeia like the noise yeah yeah or
if you have some kind of like if you
have like a signature hands to signal
your throw-up
Pepe took whoa this is getting your your
your taking this into a negative
negative way like what like I'm just
talking about if you're like yeah Dennis
this is a deep oh my god G Dennis do you
know I could i come from.he comes some
gang man yes Dennis that was hail strong
winds with your hands Stannis hails from
California so he's scared of putting up
hay enhances don't do it don't do it is
bad for you you know our our man in
Danny in the back is also from
California what do you think about that
he eat that guys from the hills oh man
everybody get neighborhoods in the show
okay okay from Cloud City so we have a
viewer who is asking police dog valley
what occasionally explain your moves
yeah okay
okay I can do my best right now I'm
trying not to flag in a losing position
period I let to heat pieces hanging at
once because I'm playing lazily and I
saw some cheap tactic that
didn't work and now I'm paying the price
for it
losing my knight on b5 maybe getting a
pawn in the exchange in return we'll see
I don't like calculating because it's
hard and I have a minute so you're
really gonna see the best that my
intuition has to offer that just played
natural moves yeah that's that's
something that var is famous for saying
it's just play just play the natural
best be easy it's just right there did
you not know that the bishop is hanging
and everything's hanging and just don't
blunder how you win well this stuff is
is hanging right now so we have a viewer
asking why not play ten minute games the
reason for that is we have only have an
hour and a half ninety minutes total for
the show we want to get as many people
playing as possible so if you get if we
play our 10 minute game
oh now so it now said Mao Mao Amato mom
out slip give us a move back no no no I
refuse this disowned you refuse okay
just go ahead and resign the game no
it's okay I'll fight on let's see I mean
so as Danny in the back pointed out that
we are having plans to do some shows
with game 10 minutes so oh he didn't
take it what who what how did he not
take the hanging Queen what was that
about he knows as a mouse lip oh well
still dude you got a crush you got to
kill me for that I don't understand
charity don't get it well you know how
like I don't know if you follow that oh
and I did it's okay I just keep hanging
it take it down what
I didn't do that that was like that when
I came in I swear yeah go ahead and just
know like yeah hi hi to test my right
right click on the bar hide
I'll put on the bottom go like just drag
it on line you know is that work alright
alright we're back we're back and this
game is done and I keep hanging stuff oh
man
this guy's just doesn't want to take
your queen yeah he knows he's flagging
me and he's dead
there he goes thank you thank you for
punishing me okay
Yamato ah yeah good game I'll give me a
pre good good game han good game maybe I
should just resign yeah Brittany says he
was being nice except a kindness and he
said I've refused to accept kindness I
can't handle it he is you used to people
being mean to him well never be kind to
me that's right that makes makes it
tough no love in this world there right
there are times where the dentists like
you can you hand hand me that pen I'll
do like this not drop it on the ground
like yeah it's what you get that's why
we're getting such good friends
ah oh you know what we're doing today
there you go who are you challenging
something I don't know I'm playing
somebody in something what their team 31
oh it looks like three is this for you
or is this yeah yes okay three two three
two okay another and it's a London okay
I got the eight eight one two three BDR
that's cool we're playing the London is
a dumb opening for white wow dude eight
eight one two he it went to three he is
just straight up eat beef right when the
game begins you're playing a dumb
opening why would you play this wow it's
gonna be a hilarious when they still got
oh this guy wins he's like oh man yeah
all right viewers let me let me get some
opinions here let's talk about who your
views of the greatest player of all time
is in chess the goat the goat I was just
kidding man the wig is a wrong topic
this is awesome so many reasons I bring
this up because I was watching ESP in
this morning's they were talking about
the goat do this go what do we what do
we consider what do I consider about
when we're talking about the greatest
all-time well you have to at least have
one world championship right that's just
yeah right well no I mean really yeah
aron nimzowitsch is up there he's aron
nimzowitsch is up there in my sometimes
do you do you see his i i scope that
back in for like that
somebody says Paul Morphy okay okay oh
man that's really gonna get them going
if we start that yeah but all Paul
Morphy benzene ring was the greatest of
all time okay so I'm sorry I'm gonna
continue what do i what do I consider
World Championships at least one how
many years you were world champion right
and your table rewriting those are my
consideration three consider at the
least three considerations the world
will be much better place with more
kindness I agree okay all right I was
joking
it was sarcasm I agree kindness is good
and I will do a better job of Wow Daniel
Rowe burger did you just change change
your picture in the past like I'm gonna
five minutes really hard to be a better
person me me okay
I said halt because home yeah you know
the life and games of me Kaltura is a
great book who who was a who was a who
at the long longest run of World
Championships who's that guy's name or
no no there was a guy who was chamber
for like
it almost like 20 years I think champion
for 20 years
anyways am I getting needed what's
what's happening here nimza wish what's
a great chess player yeah okay
yeah I there's always one guy who's
gonna be like yeah nimzowitsch move 698
yeah I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad you're
over Graham about you say he was a great
player and not the greatest all-time cuz
then we would have had a thing we had a
thing going but you know always one so
is one that look like soul Darren oh my
god I'm getting mated I'm an idiot
I'm just a big goofball just pushing
pieces around doesn't get anything stop
checking me stop keep going keep going
keep going okay thank you for not taking
it
can I survive your mating attack let's
see yeah I'm probably dying after the
knight comes in Anand
it's Kasparov Lasker I have one samsung
pad in one see ya tomorrow if I feel
like his boffin on India and then fit
Fischer and tall both was the guy from
the early part of the 1900s chat room
that also had a long run but I think
it's not saying it's that it's after
Stein is didn't Lasker hold it for a
while I think last year has the longest
run but he didn't he didn't defend it as
many times right is that was the deal
with him I believe let me double-check
on that I believe so yeah he has a long
longest reign of any official chess
player yeah that's correct
yeah but like I don't yeah
I'm hesitant from honestly answering the
question because it's someone who has
like 200 rated tournament games under
his belt or something like I more aware
than ever of a little I understand this
game um it's so like yet to say you have
a favorite means like that you get what
they're doing I don't get what they're
doing but I mean so Lasker was champion
from 1894 to 1921 so that's a oh yeah I
am in check I'm well aware of this I
just want to make sure everybody else
knew um the Lasker was champion for a
long time yeah yeah long longest run I
mean oh yeah people people say cats some
people a lot of actually a lot people
that meet say Kasparov is considered to
be like the greatest like current modern
player I'm gonna go ahead and put Magnus
in there even though his careers not
over yet he still continued on in his
prime but he's he's as far as like
prodigy goes he's up there
right Fisher and tall both consider each
other better than themselves huh huh I
think Cass brought us the best player
yeah a lot of people I meet think of
things so thank you for putting the
years on their patio last year 27 years
Kasparov 15 years yeah I guess the other
consideration is what era they played in
right arguably Kasparov's time is a lot
competition-wise a lot harder than when
Alaska was in play of course you want to
check out the greats kappa blanka yeah
cop is actually like his some of his
toes actually seems seems to be
understandable and right I really
understand until he cart Karpov the
other great from Russia and of course
horse horse was Spassky along with
Fischer pre moves um
Spassky Fischer or something ok I'm
gonna put I actually would take an on in
the consideration just because he's in
his 40s now and he's still top one of
the top in the world that's that's a
wasn't that like talent like that is
pretty on her heard of you know very
rare very rare
Danny what uh what what do you think
think of the great greatest player human
player correct we're not talking about
computers you were so so you're saying
Magnus is the greatest even though he's
still in his prime and not finish it you
could you could do a lot better
I would I that's why I put bad Magnus up
there I kind of kind of agree with him
because I I don't want it oh that's
right Danny did point out he jus Cass
brought when he was like 13 years old so
props on that I will no no just whoever
the great greatest shots were in okay so
Danny great brings up a good point he's
saying he's saying magnus carlsen who is
the greatest player just because of the
all the accomplishment he has so far
plus he's he's training with an engine
which is not done back in the back in
like ten years ago that's true yeah so
he Danny is also pointing out another
great fact now do the internet like they
can all the top grandmasters can connect
to each other and train with each other
that wasn't done before so yeah I I can
see that point that's a good point
yeah good point there was no way that
more if you would have gotten out of the
opening a liar the enemy here against
Magnus and others you have armed with
modern modern technology patio looks
like I'm sorry if I sorry if I pronounce
your name wrong
Oh some some guys said this guy's
playing worse than than me
snap yeah you know I played bed I play
bed I can admit it okay I don't all
right I'm not studying right now I'm
just bad
everyone throw Rotten Tomatoes at me
okay
oh and the guy and the guy said London
London is the best he be with a London
boy if we're talking trash that's what I
get I still think the London stinks
engine games are boring there is no
magic like tall and Braunstein would add
to the game what engine games so cheaper
oh yeah what are you talking about
traditional engines or neural networks
they so our shadow man in the back is
making the argument that these neural
networks play much more creatively than
what we're assuming you're referring to
when you talk about boring engine chests
yeah I just take their word for it I
believe them yeah apparently they're
playing oddball lines created creatively
such as the Dutch am i paraphrasing that
correctly yeah it still hurts you to
hear me say anything chess related yeah
yes are you gonna play cc [ __ ] at some
point Wow look at you well let me tell
you a little bit about the LUT know
about whatever this guy is doing what
are you doing I am gonna play c5 you're
a genius so the guy said London is a
dumb
or opening question mark are you
reconsidering that I don't know nope I
never admit I never admit what Dennis is
always gonna strongly strongly advised
against the London doesn't matter who's
playing it yeah even though yeah I mean
don't I need to get real with the
audience I play the London you guys I do
it it's true it's I I'm not like Danny
Machuca lying in bughouse
I'm telling whoa those are fighting
words man well they're just words to get
my microphone turned off no you're
actually trying to get you my girl well
I know I'm protected I'm protected they
say that in my last rated game he's
holding me accountable did I play E 4 d
4i I lost with white pieces in a French
defense meaning I play d4 hmm shame we
had a little moment everyone it's feel
good feels good break me down tear me
down people just want to lift you up in
this world Tony just so they can tear
you down that's uh yeah that's basically
how the adult world is you know one one
once you get out of the kid phase right
that's how it is that's right where's my
box of Kleenex I want to cry about it
all right the December 11th is a nonce
fiftieth birthday oh okay okay cool that
guy is awesome by the way yeah yes he's
actually met Vishwanath on a nine that
is a great guy he has a great guy very
nice they amiable
this shot is like one of those old
someone way it's a high-school amiable I
did I did go to high high school yes yes
I did yes I did I lived I'd actually do
a high school all right
which word would
like most sack worth events so sorry
yeah
cops can be horrible through the
microphone I am aware of this okay
answer the question what was the
question which word do you like most
sack or a deep defense uh trick question
question
yeah defense I like playing solid I'm
known as a super solid player that just
never takes risks that he can't
calculate his way out of that's what I
know
you guys can't hear this but Danny is
cracking up in the bag he's not it's as
true as the sky is blue um Britta is
true well Britney what Britney from
upstairs saying I'm not in such a kind
of person he is a congregation agreed
agreed Oh like that guy
yeah like when you're when you were a
top chess player hmm
like for to find a top chess player as
as nice as he is is rare it's rare it is
much this hey I have a past fun so he's
gonna move he's going up
sorry viewers I'm actually just on our
Twitter account seeing what's going on
make sure all of our stuff is on social
media so you guys can know about it make
sure to follow us Facebook Twitter
Instagram
Samuel is chess club STL chess club is
our handle follow us and you can get a
heads up on anything that's coming up
okay
somebody said you are a good question
what I don't what I don't know how to
take that yeah their question and why do
I want to play an on is one of the top
Nonna's one of the best player chess
players in mind on my top list yeah are
ours too are soo thank you for weighing
in why you gotta be so condescending man
I'm not trying to be kind that was me
being sincere oh that was your sincere
voice okay got it got it I'm just that
ill adjusted Tony that you can't tell
when I'm trying to become well one of
our viewers said you play better than
alpha zero oh there you go there you go
that's something I keep forgetting I'm
playing increment and I'm not doing this
right I'm just not gonna do a little
check the root check guy check goes
risky yeah Queen c4 that's what you want
all right I got a question for you one
of our viewers one wants you to fill
fill in the blank chess players life is
like a blank there's like a human life
what's the flash fourth on planet earth
that's what the chess players like like
it's like it's like a human life on
planet Earth
dude obviously are very least there's a
similarity there can we agree we agree I
agree with you I think everybody you
agree but one of our viewers is looking
for something a little bit deeper deeper
you are the you are lhasa fir once GM
jesse cry leaves you are the resident
philosopher yeah I don't know gets
applause that's a burden I'm willing to
bear I'll try I'll try and live
- it all singles Chess Club logo looks
great thank you very much Sun scary
thank you very much
give I'll give a hats off to our
graphics team they did they spend a lot
of time designing that so you know yeah
go graphics team everybody is great I'm
losing this game
Hey then Dennis is being sour cuz he's
not his skis
what's your right record i'll more long
losses i'm doing poorly but this guy
just wants to do me a favor thanks buddy
wow he's turned gonna start
trash-talking now after getting of he is
gonna start trash-talking doesn't even
put material yeah material yeah but like
yeah dude i'm i did not play i did not
have I was not lucky enough to play in
scholastic tournaments directed by Tony
Chen and so I did not learn about good
sportsmanship
okay yeah I tried that's true no would
talk oh gosh I I did for many years
direct all those classic tournaments
here the same with Chess Club I am no
longer doing that spot yeah I one of my
key key points I was trying to make her
kisses good sportsmanship good sports
you learned that when you're young you
don't want to turn turn out to be like
this this guy yeah good game smacking
Hannah yeah that happens that happens
true story it does happen then there's a
time where he's just like he was he was
not knocking down his King to resign
he's knocked down the floor what things
like they don't did that somebody did
that it was it appreciate was you why
did what you like you I knocked my king
down you were resigning your king and
knocking abutting used to run the ground
you like screw this I've never done it
oh that's not all right now you're
you're spreading ugly lies about me Tony
what are you talking about ugly lies
well I'm gonna lose this game because
somebody said back rank mate dude I
missed it back rank mate yeah do believe
them um I know that I'm winning
this game if I can just move fast which
which chess format which time control do
you hiking that best which time control
do I do best at the one where I don't
have to talk women down on the clock
hold on
do I have okay I have a little time to
burn now all right little time what
happened I lie logically yeah I don't
even know how that no big deal
good job screwed I I don't know what
you're doing you cannot just as
acquaintances that disappeared off the
board I think I've removed her onto an
attack squared it's okay we're gonna
demonstrate some technique right now I
think great carlini is one of the best
trash talkers in amateur chess who is
that I don't I actually don't like that
guy yeah but no get Roe burger put up a
link to Sunstone something we're gonna
check it out Brittany says I'm impressed
at the notion of Tony and good
sportsmanship so let me give you a
little context of why she's saying that
guy it's because because when when I'm
talking with Brittany his co-workers I
talked about the trash talk to her it's
for fun technique she doesn't realize
home hey one point good job yep nice try
Scoob done nice try
I'm horrible at everything except bear
queen against or against Queen against
Perry King so viewers if there's a way
okay
there's a way you can challenge us to a
game where you have five minutes and
then dennis has like 20 that'd be hard
to be best if that's what you're asking
about
hey wait do I have a plus score if I
I've won more games than I've lost today
that's all we care that true right yeah
that's what we're saying okay that's
what we're saying more than we lost
oh I'm feeling so good I'm gonna take on
this guy sighs crushing your opponent
yes he is another guy said laughing
laughing means you're a weak chess
player well you know he's he's saying
laughing my book you know it's not a kid
kid for a friendly show so I'm like I
said that we're entertaining him Oh
dude this guy I'm playing I don't know
hey Tom Oh mm all right yeah get us some
points in yeah well no he's playing he's
playing like he's playing in an
ungentlemanly fashion would you like me
to pull up an engine as a matter of fact
I would I think this guy is
ungentlemanly behavior he refused my
gambit oh no that's rude yeah that is
all just through slap a guy in the face
yeah if somebody offers you something
you should take it you should take it
yeah
thank you Tony yeah somebody said how do
I become a toxic player it's my dream a
toxic player at what what is what oh is
that a term that we should know I guess
I mean does yeah I don't even really
want to go there is that restroom okay
I'm toxic I think that's just like a
colloquial term like meaning like yeah
like a downer and kind of a mean well
how do you become a toxic player dent
Dennis what what what's your life like
how how should that this guy Lynne I
drink lots of soda you don't want fast
food coffee coffee is a big thing yeah
lots of coffee um every time you feel
like exercising take a nap instead yeah
there you go Britney says good job
Dennis show them skills yeah yeah I got
skills that pay some bills all right
what is happening I'm attacking your
queen that's what I'm doing you know I'm
getting a safety what 37 37 viewers
that's unacceptable yeah pull up all the
media devices you have the motor need to
turn on to our stream how good yeah
Britney says let's not talk about engine
Tony all right let's talk about Brit
that's how about for a second that's not
hot she's a she's a great person
debatable
now she is session very nice if you ever
in st. Louis in a chess club comes like
hi she's here almost every she's here
every week that's right no all I know is
that stuff is stuff is stuff I'm not
down pause that's all there is to it
okay I wonder if the reason why we have
fewer viewers is because we don't have a
GM plane yeah it probably I mean you
there also oh yeah that's right there
streaming world the world yes true but
they would rather watch that than us
yeah Dan so Danny saying there's you
know they're watching like all the big
tournament world champions with yes true
agreed Arian says how can I join these
games I don't know
Aryan you can challenge Osaka chess calm
Danny's gonna put a link on the chat
again so you can click on it and
challenge the game radio games only this
time control just give you a context for
anybody who's new there's a 30 second
gap between what we say and what you see
you know so if you know so if you see
how it's kind of weird when you're
you're typing in the chat and what we
talk about that's why that is the why of
it is the why of it is this a gauntlet
where you guys just having fun playing
people randomly
we're playing rent playing for randomly
basically if you challenge us we see and
we'll try to get to you it is for fun
but it is also for reigning points on
chess calm so radio games only
yeah and they might yeah I mean my which
piece is most poisonous most sadi okay
talking about no idea no idea sir cool
cool I don't know what I'm supposed to
play here but let's try this one
you're supposed to play good good you're
just supposed to play the best no
blunders no blunders dude my move too is
like routinely a blunder some would
claim I think it's but you are winning
on time that's all I know let's not talk
about it because you might jinx me
superstitious Wow yeah I can't be that
kind of person
oh yeah the superstition is it's totally
sound logic uh totally sound logic oh
here we go is there an increment in this
or not
somebody tell me I don't know Mike Lissy
after he makes a move let's see what
happens
well there isn't the time control on the
screen somewhere and I'm just blind is
is there I know yeah I I don't plan to
try fast comm so I've really no idea but
it's five oh yeah oh here we go
toxic Mia that's the case toxic is a
term used in multiplayer games to
describe someone who trash talks a lot
it's a gamer thing okay so how do you
become a toxic player
um that's a good question what's a
popular how do you we're aiming for
toxicity yeah how do you change your
personality to nice from nice to to not
very not nice well I mean I think we're
oversimplifying things to begin with
we're starting from an over simple over
simple starting point which is that the
world can be neatly divided into nice
people and not nice people I don't think
that's really the case but you know what
am i some kind of you know you know what
you do you move to a super big city
uh-huh like let's say for you you eat in
the u.s. let's say New York City where
everybody's just like New York City on a
different level or mean meanness
so like dude maybe your personality will
change that way you can also play a
chess against some hustlers in the park
and they just like you know run run
their mouths entire time you can learn
you can learn a lot of things
learning's one of our greatest one of
our friends of the chess club is
grandmaster Maurice Ashley that guy have
you go on YouTube and search Maurice
Ashley trash talk that guy is just like
to to quote run-run dtmc he says runs
his mouth like Shh the entire time that
was a Run DMC quote yeah you just runs
his mouth like well actually somebody
said that about Run DMC but you know I
think potato potato
whoever says potato I've never heard
anyone say potato or this guy who's work
tomorrow which English is not his first
language boom
are you trying to make make fun of me
yes how dare you
no all right here we go um okay which
square do you like most and why
do you like most square one in the
center how predictable I'm all about h8
h8 is neglected he's really yeah so so
you're you're saying and if there was an
actual war going on instead of
controlling the high you want you want
you want to try to control but you want
the trench okay that's cool everybody
has their own ways of fighting you know
is this guy it might something happening
here what's happening um Brittany says
interesting question for chest circle
perhaps we should have a class on good
sportsmanship that would be so cool oh I
cool yes I don't know how well we see
that would be I think if we had a class
on trash-talking that'd be more eCourse
on that and then good sportsmanship but
yeah yeah as some somebody who likes to
teach kids goose worship yes yes yeah
Tony yeah
hey well this guy's just would you stop
trying to checkmate me
you heard what you said stop trying to
checkmate him resigned yeah wait some
points man give us some points just
leave me alone
just leave me and I
okay I don't want you to checkmate me
I'm not gonna let you check maybe just
leave me alone
okay we're cool cool work okay good game
it's not over till it's over friends all
right let's hope that this guy has a big
mouth slip and then terrassa came for us
what's happening someone's who hey we
got a draw against the torture mm yeah
we got a timeout versus insufficient
material what a joke still still a still
eight points for us good game we
heighten one of our viewers said you
guys are so you guys are amazing taking
every question that's cool we try we try
some um we try yeah
ask us anything chess related or
personal if you want to I don't know I
can't guarantee we're gonna answer
personal questions yeah I'll try I don't
know what why am i why is Dennis so
good-looking I don't know that's uh
that's coming on your mind that's not on
the chat here oh I think something is
very handsome
and he seems to be an endless wellspring
I believe that yeah humor and
intelligence
I believe the chat says told Dennis
throw up a sign that's what you saying
throw up a sign man throw my hand hand
signal you you you can you there you go
we can do one of those like baseball
things like you're out of here yeah like
you know it's throw one of those Danish
gambit
hi Rajesh what's up hi Tom says thanks
for the game thank you thank you good
thank you for playing us thank you for
joining us appreciate it okay who's
already played this a one to three
fellow so okay another high rated player
all right I'm taking you guys on right
here's a question from one of our
viewers any advice for a 1400 player who
gets crushed by 1800 friends every time
you look because he's actually for 1400
yes that's true yes I'm 1,400 in my
floor yes right now I live on the floor
yeah
it's true it's true somebody said you
guys are amazing great games thank you
very much sorry you think you're very
much appreciated thanks if you get
anything good to say let our bosses know
info just about that horror yeah I want
somebody there right into info s English
at work and be like Tony and Dennis are
the best here we go let me type on the
chat for you there is our there's the e
email so you can email us give them some
good comments I want to raise some good
comments here we go all right I tsuneo
says I am 32 and I want to develop chess
more and more want to be 2,100 oh my
currently is 1400 so what what uh was my
advice yeah give up no no you asked the
perfect person because he is very
similar to you
he's very similar yeah i won except that
chess is a subject that seems to be as
complicated and involved as far as
learning goes as a language and so just
like you wouldn't or you shouldn't
demand of yourself to learn a foreign
language especially if it's like
something radically foreign to whatever
culture you may be coming from um you
shouldn't expect yourself to yeah jump
up into you know like Nobel laureate
level literacy and chess and instead
yeah I don't know I've learned to live
with in the 80th percentile or wherever
1400 puts yet on anyway that's my advice
so if you're really serious about it
what your most of the advice you're
gonna hear is gonna sound something like
focus heavy on tactics get a regular
coach play tournaments regularly you
have to play rated tournaments if you
want to get
a chest there's just no way every every
GM we have here they will always tell
everyone it won't tell you you need to
play in more tournaments because not
nothing you mean you can prep all you
want to study all you want but actual
experience is key here one of our
viewers said fun session thank you very
much we try we try and we're doing our
best science OSA neo says suggesting why
you're playing just like speaking asleep
what what what I'm playing oh yeah yeah
okay yeah okay I think it was oh he says
thank you just thank you I'm trying yeah
we will try try you can also instead of
like asking you can if you have any
questions aside from one word on stream
you can always email us influence
yourself let me ask a question and we'll
we'll geek it will definitely get back
to you our club manager Jon Shan Shan's
and assistant manager here Dennis Alou
they all have but they both have access
to those emails so they can see who
writes in and they will answer your
questions pretty fairly taste quickly
are you playing against Bianca mm hey
not as good this game is not as good as
the last one let's try it go go for a
draw here draw I mean you're gonna go go
for a pond that's going to refute the
Sicilian I'm refuting the Sicilian
Bianca you're not gonna go for the point
O which fun the d6 pawn that's the point
of the move yeah that's the point
I claim just general pressure on the D
file and this week d5 square give us
some more there's more deep with some
more of my deep chest inside people want
to want to have you talk about the moves
you play that's fair that's fair here
we've got I don't know yeah we're
playing this and seeing what I am trying
to just I'm trying to get my pawn back
in a dubious fashion I think is the
shorthand version to play a move like
this you have to
calculate everything all the way we have
we have to two questions for you ask me
personally which coffee do you like most
strong coffee strong coffee there you go
he like he's one of those like I like it
black yeah
no no creamer no sure don't know
anything give me the egg me the darkest
coffee right
that's right he yeah he like he likes it
bitter you know like this that's true to
match that to matches personality that's
how to come play some chess today I am
like a second question do you prefer
open or closed positions well if we're
sticking with my little story that I was
telling about how I'm well known for
being a super solid player I just aim
for a nice close center and I out play
you with my superior positional whatever
it is but no I was poisoned at some
point by reading them that me call tall
book and I developed some fantasy idea
of being a tactical player and move
right now yeah yeah and so I like open
positions because I think I can play
them and then I always realize that I
can't so let me ask you if you let me
see if you agree with this stuff oh my
gosh I'm dying oh actually this guy says
first Queen Queen c7 question for black
Queen c7 is probably crushing for black
yeah I'm not doing right here um okay
let's just rub it in everybody's alright
that was it okay calm down people calm
down all right
here let me see if you agree with this
playing for a draw with white is a crime
that's why the joke is that the London
is bad Oh another on that are oh gosh
and I'm just saying I can't play chess
and talk yeah yesterday McGlothlin used
to make fun of me for playing the London
all the time oh he said never mind queen
sita's not crushing because you have
bishop takes f7 I'm not gonna pay
attention to the game yeah yeah I had
some tactic there but whatever I had is
all long gone and now I don't even know
I'm just playing out of momentum really
Wow in the 20 seconds I didn't watch
this you are just like getting I'm
getting mopped up and getting and it
hurts it just hurts to live okay
good game dude I'm out of here I'm out
hey your uh your your front hole from
what from walnuts on what is he saying
hello Tony Dennis hello we're doing
great thank you for joining us play but
challenge me
yeah challenge chess calm there's a link
in the chat somewhere maybe Danny will
put it up again but challenging chess
calm radio games blitz time control only
how well we are actually doing fantastic
how how are things going in Cali on
yours south side of the country yeah
what's the weather like out there yeah
don't is donut tree still open do you
guys still play just a donut tree I we
got questions for you yeah I I think we
asked him that last time he said yes did
he I know I think I just mentioned don't
entry yeah
yeah I said thank a good game thank you
thank you for the game thank you yeah
let me yeah don't get me started on the
wedding like st. Louis now is just
getting into fall / one winter it's
getting pretty pretty cold outside and I
don't like it but what are you gonna do
it makes me it makes me so jealous of
all the southern states
don't be jealous I'm jealous
remember the seasons build character
that's why you're such a well rounded
he's how easy to be around person yeah
because yeah you know how to make it
through all four seasons and you know a
little baby like me I gotta wear
sweaters the minute it hits 60 degrees I
gotta I I will say I lived in southern
Florida for a while and it was like it
was just never cold there and
when I lived there I actually missed the
winner for us I know some of the times I
was like so I get it why it's it's good
to have all four seasons rolling around
makes just strong emotionally basically
you playing somebody come on they're
scared of me there we go all right 1070
our eyes actually we're Hey time flies
look and again dear Dan we're almost at
oh wow yeah we have like about ten
minutes left
holy crap I did not yeah yeah and since
we're keeping close tabs I've definitely
won more games than I've lost let's just
say yeah let's say that's true
16:53 what did the ratings start at at
17 or something yeah 70 something ahora
from Wallace says Gabe now teaches chess
good about 12 young students his school
has website Romo chess Academy Romo
Jessica great great so that is actually
a big big trend nowadays like people are
starting their own clothes especially
here in st. Louis there's like a lot of
individual clubs that are teaching chess
so young young kids and they're trying
to play against each other so it's
pretty cool I like saying I like hearing
that that's awesome yeah that is yeah so
on and he actually is a mutual student
of someone that our shadow man in the
back knows that Gabe Romo character took
lessons with Matthew Bilby who is a
master that we so Danny was always
commenting that Gabe is now taking
personal lessons with Daniel King who I
don't know who that is
I've seen some kind of mass must be yeah
it must be a total player I don't know
Danny you know what that is Daniel King
GM where I am GM so Danny's informing us
that Daniel King is GM and he is famous
for doing what is it lots of DVDs DVDs
okay so will I like to check them out
now I know about it the name yep bah bah
bah ro burger it's same weather in
Sweden very cold I feel you man I feel
you
I'm actually dreading the day is when
it's gonna be like you know 20 degrees
some sometimes it goes in the net
negatives here and it's a brutal rude oh
whoa whoa okay my did you did you do
something are you guys okay back there
hold on yeah yeah it looks like can I
hit reload oh it looks like we're back
hold on it looks like everything is fine
okay cool everything's fine everything
sorry everybody
um no I I may or may not have hit the
power switch on the search screen yep
surge protector anyway let's not live
somebody said Daniel King has a YouTube
channel cool I will definitely check it
out now for sure what is well since
we're talking about yeah I I wonder yet
what skate does gameplay USCF is does he
have a rating right now I'm gonna look
him up tell the truth okay Gabriel Romo
I got you here we go I remember ya
anyway yeah just a little contig I that
we're talking to him in a group of other
guys were very similar to like the group
of dudes that comes in after work hours
and plays blitz up up there like Chuck
and Farrow and the rest all right
Gabriel Gabriel Romo from California
1378 yep okay provisional of 23 all
right okay
keep playing keep rate great job
really you don't know we're talking
about GM Daniel King ha I don't to be at
to be honest with you when I follow the
chess world it's only the top players
yeah and and then for for those of us
like the a-class there's all the eight
classes know everybody yeah we had to
talk to the a-class a lot and they take
it easy man oh and and howa you're
saying Gabe is about 22 to 23 hundred
that's not that's not sure is USCF is 13
something you guys is that it like
skilled level corner how it is in places
where we don't or we don't have a lot of
rated games everyone so whatever we say
they are all right you need to you have
years some friends when Cali watching
this you need to I need to step it up
and what is this I don't even know how
to play this position somebody tell me
Danny give us a move in trouble you know
we just play on the queenside cuz we're
better on the Queens that sounds good
sounds good
I'll leave it up to you I got this how
much time do I have 3:19 I'm down a
little on time but I'm Way up on rate
yeah so for viewers were after this game
we'll probably take one more Challenger
then then our time will be up so make
sure you wanna play us today make sure
you challenge us yeah one more game left
one more game
one more game one more cup of coffee for
the road it's oh I've got this comment
so you know how like you look on you hit
that you hit that the cord with your leg
yes shut him on me know somebody is like
you guys got hacked by opponent yes yes
we did we did not hit the core without a
leg got act yeah that's yes neck same
I'll play you sir okay
Shamir make sure to make sure to
challenge us all right what's uh what's
your what's your check with your chess
calm handle let's make sure we know that
thank you for spending time and respond
to my in certain questions we love doing
that that's where that's why I really
that's the point of this you can talk to
you guys we want to know what's going on
in your neck of the woods we want to
know what your thoughts are if you have
any suggestions for any new new
material new shows let us know always
looking forward to people writing good
things about us on info chess it up
chess club org yeah good thing
goodbye had a lot of fun 12 a.m. here oh
thank you for thank you for joining us
hopefully you join us tomorrow again
noon local time alright hope to see you
tomorrow what did I do wrong
what'd you do wrong you accept the
challenge I accepted the challenge I
agree that was a mistake
Danny is there any way you could like
hack into this computer and play as
Dennis what is that is that doable Danny
said did Danny says yes it's probably
doable so we're gonna try that tomorrow
are we Tony is that good sportsmanship
Tony Cheng I think so maybe it's it's
debatable so I'm not gonna I can't
answer that right now you know and
someone please teach me how to play
chess you need to just win win on time
now make a move okay all right oh you're
showing on time dang whoa how short of
my own time 241 337 thought of going on
a minute-by-minute okay that's cool
that's cool
well dude this guy's dan dan the air is
1070 you just I need to just win this
come around I mean this guy around let's
set a new goal we want our ready to be
1665 how about that six things 65 give
me two points in it again we gave you oh
my god like achievable goals I feel like
you may or may not be patronizing me but
I can tell I so I feel like I set up on
a 10 will go for you by getting trying
to get to see ya so I apologize about
that's my fault
I apologize hey guys I just tried so
hard to make Tony proud I failed son
scurry said Magnus won
cool that's to be expected world
champion if I was gonna bet on anybody
maybe the world champion always bet on
the best sounds like the might come
really I just feel like I feel like
that's all the thought process for a lot
of people always why don't you what if
you're gonna bear some of you why not
bet on the best Oh
a little credence to a possibility and
say anything I would have thought that
why they give that might would not bet
on the best cuz he's just yeah he's out
yeah it's true he is kind of about the
the sole underdog type thing
yeah you're catching up on time good job
this one not looking good everything's
looking fine everything is looking fine
tell me Jen
everything is perfectly fine whoa
attacking attacking centralizing okay
yeah to the amateur it may appear to be
an attack but it's actually just a
routine sequence I hate you so much
right now alright it's Mon it's on now
it's gonna be all the dices
this guy missed this that's gonna be
toxic yeah this is how you be a toxic
chess player you play nice and then
surprise people by being rude
so apparently anyway so one of our
viewers is saying there's a break in the
tournament that's a big tournament that
streaming so viewers are incoming thank
God in the last three minutes let's have
an extra four forty or forty viewers how
about that yeah yeah yeah yeah extra
viewers life is good
I want to go here or I want to go here
somebody tell me what to do with my life
let's take the pond yeah
now to the amateur taking the pawn might
seem like the correct move so why so why
did you do it then I had to spin around
had to spin around you're too strong he
means that physically yeah weight weight
lifting is probably it was definitely
without a doubt a lot stronger than what
yeah I lift myself up in a cruel and
malicious world I lift myself up Tony
that's a that's a tough i bottom by my
bootstraps that's tough
Danny do you think we have another type
of the time for another game after this
but yeah so the hell he's assuming here
I'm gonna win so just because I'm
winning yeah so the answer from Danny is
let's finish on a high note so we're
gonna assume that Danny's I mean dennis
is gonna win this and we're gonna end it
yeah I actually didn't realize this game
was gonna take so long so this probably
pee pee our last game and everybody it
was fun though yeah hopefully you guys
we did it it's fun
well we'll try to I I will try to
improve on my trash-talking game all
right and then hopefully we can have
more fun next time well if you're having
fun then you're probably not a very
strong chess player Wow okay all right
hey hey is the word life all about being
a strong chess player if you are in the
chess world yes which thankfully I'm not
really so we are in the chess world
deafening dang sure here come here two
one seven you know you're so sure Mirai
I take back what I said earlier we we
don't have a time for another game I
miss sorry I did accept someone's
request to be the friend of this chest
icon the possum which rasam so I'm here
I apologize if you
after this game we're gonna have to end
if you join us tomorrow at the same time
we'll try to definitely get to you man
I'm sorry about this drawing is the
first calculation is not my strong suit
that's why I don't play la chess so dude
yeah I played a lot of chess you know
calculating is overrated
yeah natural babe hey we can appoint all
right we didn't gain - that's okay
that's okay okay all right everyone we
are fishing all the time thank you very
much for joining us make sure to join us
tomorrow same time noon local time and
we will have another fun show all right
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club